[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
former patriot wide receiver danny
amendola
was on first things first on fox sports
1 yesterday morning
and he was asked about the patriot way
and the former wide receiver had this to
say when you see
patriot way in the dictionary it's going
to have tom brady's name next to it
none of those coaches do any passes none
of those coaches caught any passes none
of those coaches
made any tackles they got guys in the
right position because they watched a
lot of film and they spent all their
time at the facility
but but tom brady is the patriot way and
that's and that's the reason why
tom brady's in the super bowl right now
and and the patriots aren't
all righty sounds like a smooth segway
to bring in matt light spent a decade
there with the patriots won three super
bowls there
founder of the light foundation and matt
kind enough to join us
what did you make of amendola's comments
there matt
i mean it kind of sounded a little bit
like an angry elf right
one of those south pole elves you know
uh
maybe he was trying to make a point
there about something and
uh seems to be working you know look
when i was there you know my 11 seasons
with bill
you know it was a roller coaster of
emotions there were days where
you didn't want to hear it from bill you
didn't want to hear the early morning
all right look you guys are terrible
we're never going to win a game if you
guys keep playing like this this is the
worst football i've ever seen
here let's watch light 700 times
screwing up a block you know like
it gets old and by the way it can get
really personal especially
when you mix in contract talk right and
the fact that guys do
give up you know the ability to
potentially go make more money
elsewhere so is it personal
with him at this point right now sure
seems like it but
i think there's some truth in what he
says though you know to me
if somebody asked me who embodies and
who is the face of the patriot way
kind of hard to argue the point that
it's tom brady take me back to the
decision
when belichick decided to stay with
brady even
when drew bledsoe came back from that
injury so 2001
you've just paid drew he's one of the
highest paid players in the game and you
got
a guy you're not quite sure how good he
is and brady's won a few games and then
he decides to stay with him as a
teammate
and an aw you know somebody blocking for
these quarterback what did you think of
that move at the time
yeah i mean it was it was like okay we
had the mo lewis hit
heard around the world you know we have
the hundred million dollar man
you know largest contract i think at the
time in nfl history
and we had the back up to the back up
right i mean tommy wasn't number two in
camp
he was number three i think it was
michael bishop and i don't know i've
been hit a lot but
you know so you know yeah i mean it was
it was an interesting point in time
i can remember though in that season
we're on the road
playing in washington and we almost came
back in the fourth quarter to win
a road game that at the time it was
still kind of
unknown can he do it can he not do it
you know when's drew gonna be back
but even though we didn't win that game
on the road everybody
felt you know that that tommy had what
it was going to take after that game
and then you fast forward to the afc
championship game and he leaves with an
injury
comes you know drew bledsoe comes back
in he's throwing darts down the sideline
and then we're going to the super bowl
with no week in between i mean it was
chaos
but um you know look as weird as that
situation was
it was really clear that tom brady was
the leader but
be honest after the afc title game
bledsoe comes in
throwing darts you guys win you're going
to super bowl
if i would ask you then who do you want
to start that super bowl
who would you have picked you know
honestly
you kind of had to go i mean i felt
terrible for the situation for drew
bledsoe
i mean here we are going to a super bowl
this guy's put in so much work in the
national football league
and comes back in for that you know afc
championship game and picks up right
where he left off but
even with that said as much as i love
drew bledsoe
you know i i really felt like tommy
earned the right to have that
opportunity at that point but he didn't
throw any touchdowns
in the playoffs leading up to the super
bowl he didn't throw a touchdown pass
yeah it's a stat that i didn't know i
mean you wouldn't know that if you're in
our locker room right
and by the way you're talking to an
offensive lineman i mean you know just
point me in the right direction
you know wind me up and let me go but
how much credit do you give
belichick belichick doesn't get credit
for making this
move right i mean as much as we can say
well who's more responsible for the
patriots success belichicker
belichick made the ultimate decision
to start tom brady over drew bledsoe
i mean he's got to get credit for that
yeah
and and what a huge point too i mean you
look at the the previous season
or two right and you know the lack of
kind of people buying into the patriot
way and what it meant
and and the idea that you know we're
going to sacrifice a lot more than just
what some other teams were doing and how
they prepared
because when you come to new england you
give up quite a bit you know
especially kind of you know who you are
in some ways everything gets muted
for the benefit of the overall
organization but yeah i mean look
bill's made some unbelievably tough
calls that
you know seemed kind of uncharacteristic
for a head coach to make i mean i think
about
you know that season in 2002 i think it
was it was the following year after we
won the super bowl
lawyer malloy gets shipped down to you
know buffalo
the desert right and you know he was the
best one of our one of our leaders i
mean clearly one of our leaders and one
of the guys that everybody looked to
i mean that blew my mind so you know you
never knew what to expect but at the end
of the day
you know what we did know is that bill
talked a lot about
the decisions he makes or what's in the
best interest of the team and i know
that that's something that coaches say
but i truly believe that that's what
bill and his entire staff
do even though it seems strange at times
how much of a role did belichick have in
your
tenure there with the patriots with the
offense
uh you know it's it's it's an
interesting question because
you know we had really strong people
that were coaching
the offensive side of the ball right
like i look back and
you know charlie weiss you know you know
he was going to tell
coach what he wanted to do and why he
thought that was the way to go and
and and there's always struggles on a
coaching staff right
the offensive line coach is pushing for
more pass plays the quarterback
especially tom brady and the quarterback
coaches are all looking for different
ways to you know get fancy and cute with
the ball
and and so there's this struggle on on
play calls and how we open
and who's really the offensive
coordinator on some staffs but
bill you know to answer your question
bill belichick had a lot to do with our
offense
you know everybody talks about him as a
defensive coach but
you know bill really understands
you know not just the scheme but but how
the other side is gonna look at
you know defending against what you do
best right and bill's a big proponent of
hey
here's the three things that we have to
do that that's what we did before every
matchup
here's what we have to do offensively
here's what we have to do on the
defensive side the ball and here's what
we have to do on special teams and
there'll be three points to each week
as we prepared so you know he he knew as
much of on the offensive side
as he certainly did on the defensive
side who do you think is most
responsible
for what happened in those two decades
in new england
i mean look i think if if anybody looks
at this season
and tries to make a comparison at this
point in time
how about this man how about this how
about this you can have belichick
as your coach or brady as your
quarterback
this is your rookie year yeah i mean
you gotta go with bill belichick for a
lot of reasons
right um can can he win without tom
brady yeah
i think he can i mean we did in 2008
right if you want a case study to look
at
you know we had a guy in matt castle you
know
who filled in did a great job same coach
same bill belichick right so i don't
look at what happened this season
and try to compare it in in the realm of
who's more important tom brady or bill
belichick
look those are two of the most dynamic
people to play in the game right
but you think you could have won super
bowls with bledsoe
yeah yeah i think we could for sure okay
you know
yeah i wouldn't put either one of those
guys down right i mean but it is a
system right
new england is a system kind of scheme
i mean it always has been always will be
with bill belichick as the head coach
but tom
though he's a system unto himself isn't
he he is now
he is now okay and look he has been for
a long time
so you know look is it there's no
surprise that tom brady's in the super
bowl right the fact that he went to
tampa kind of shocked me
you know there's a lot of things that i
found interesting i didn't think that
you know i wasn't somebody that said hey
just because tom brady's in tampa
they're going to go to the super bowl
but it's not a surprise
do you ever have a drink with belichick
i've been drinking around him
i i saw him i remember when the
transition happened
and he went from like only football and
everything in football
to then the bill belichick that we kind
of know now today that will
maybe go down to the islands and enjoy a
little bit more golf so
i've seen him relax and cut loose do you
have a belichick story
that i haven't heard i've got a vault
but you can't get in trouble now matt oh
listen you just looked over your
shoulder when i asked you that question
as if as if there was somebody there
going matt don't do that
yeah like my wife was worried that i was
gonna get fired or let go
every week every week because i was
always up to something that was no good
all right give me a belly check story
all right so
uh there was a time and i've told this
before but this is a great one
there was a time where at the pro bowl
and we had one of my teammates that was
there
as well and he came as an alternate and
i told him while he was hanging out with
a lot of guys that were
more tenured than he that when you're at
the pro bowl you don't pay for drinks
and especially if you're if your
coaching staff is there i said hey look
here's bill's room
and i i made it a point to get bill's
room number
and i said just fill it out put his room
number on there
and and sign his name so i thought it
would be funny i didn't think he would
actually do it but
hey we're just having fun a little
conversation well i
about five hours later and after he'd
been hanging out with all the old-timers
who were already putting all their
drinks on his bill anyway which he
didn't know
now the young bucks never figure that
out until it's too late i see him
walking from one side of the pool area
to the other
to hand bill the check card it's in his
hand
and i'm the only person in the whole
area that knew what was happening
so i remember i grabbed i grabbed one of
my teammates i'm like
bro you've got to see this you have no
idea what's about to happen but it's
going to get weird
and and he walks up he's like i
appreciate you bill i appreciate you and
bill has no idea what he's talking about
but he did
sign it and he did pay for it
uh brady uh was a pretty good beer
chugger right
one of the best yeah for sure yeah ross
tucker said that he was
he he was up there yeah you you won't
you won't see any evidence of that i
think that stopped many years ago about
the time the whole tb12 method came out
apparently
water saved you from getting a burn more
than alcohol so
what if we were doing shots of kale do
you think that he would be
great at chugging kale just stay away
from strawberries and everything else is
okay
but he wasn't different or strange when
you were there
um no i mean look he's always had his
method
i mean from the very beginning a matter
of fact before before he was ever the
starter
when i got to new england the only
person i knew in the new england
region was a guy named dave nugent who i
went to purdue with and was a roommate
and came in with a class the year before
with tom brady
so you know i got to see tommy you know
as the guy driving the yellow jeep that
was given to him by the dealer that
wasn't the starter and
but but even then you know the guy
always had a method to everything he did
and was always trying to do it at a very
high level but what happens when he
shows up with gisele
were you were you still there when
gisele makes her first appearance or you
find out brady is dating gisele
yeah yeah i was there when they were
married i mean it was uh
yeah i mean there there were some other
interesting moments before that too that
that
you know we we poked fun at but yeah
yeah i mean we we saw the whole
transformation
and the clothes and like just everything
about him
he had a makeover right well
now now you're gonna force me to do this
okay so
imagine this for me dan okay i'm an
offensive lineman i roll out of bed at 6
00 a.m we have a team meeting at 7 00
a.m
every single day if you're late you're
probably going to be fired
we've actually seen evidence of that in
the form of a running back right so
you're not going gonna be late but when
i roll out of bed as an offensive
lineman
fat sweaty sloppy i don't do anything
other than just put on whatever was
laying next to my bed i walk into the
facility
i drop all that stuff put on my workout
stuff and i walk into the meeting right
let me contrast that with a tom brady
when tom brady walks in and on this
particular day
he comes in with the skinny jeans that
taper all the way to a very tight
point with the designer boots that were
made by tom ford custom designed
you know unbelievable leather the whole
nine polished to the nth degree
on the upper half of him he's wearing a
cardigan i'm i'm talking straight out of
like mr rogers cardigan and this
cardigan
has a giant lapel it's got wool knitted
by some sherpa
in the himalayas it has hand carved
buttons the size of like my hand that
are really cool looking
and i'm kind of angry that this is what
i see walking in so i bust his chops all
the time
and on this particular day i decided it
was a good opportunity for me to go to
his locker while he was working on
becoming a better player and studying
plays
and i put on his so-called
sherpa cardigan and i went and i worked
out in it
now the fun part is is that the only
thing i put on was the cardigan
literally the only thing so
when he was driving home to his
beautiful place in boston
where i knew he wasn't going to be able
to get away from the ickiness
of me sending a picture of working out
in that cardigan
i took a lot of joy in that
did he keep it i i think he'd probably
burn it on the side of 93.
oh it's great to touch base with you
again matt hope you're doing well
and uh the light foundation as well um
you know thanks for joining us we love
the stories well i appreciate it listen
the best story line of this super bowl
is sherm fightsforfreedom.org anthony
sherman fullback for the kansas city
chiefs
he's given away his truck anybody can
get an opportunity
to take home that man's truck and he's
one of the the best guys on that team
one of the leaders
and if you go to that website
shermanfightsforfreedom.org you'll be
supporting
the fight against human trafficking and
supporting our military so
cool little back story on him he's a
north uh attleboro massachusetts guy and
we wish him luck and love the fact that
he's doing what he's doing
give me that address again sherm fights
for freedom
anthony sherman his truck anybody can
get an opportunity it's a giveaway
there's also cool prizes because his
teammates are jumping in
i hear that pat mahomes is jumping in on
this too but kelsey's in
he's signing jerseys we got country
music artists the whole nine
so it's a cool giveaway you're a good
man matt thanks for joining us
appreciate you dan that's matt light
former patriots offensive tackle
a nice little appearance out of nowhere